what else do you guys use to like keep
you on track because I feel like I
suffer from this I just go like this
watch talk to me while I'm working hey
[Music]
so there was an employee at a Sonic
drive-in restaurant love that place just
doing his [__] job was he on skates
no oh he was why the [__] would you ask
that dude sorry he was cooking
do the cookware skates okay what the
[__] are you talking about so he's just
doing his job right and sometimes in
America when you're doing your job you
get accused of doing things that's
messed up
and this guy sometimes in America yeah
so this guy's making a hot dog order
right and he's preparing the order and
the customer gets the hot dog and the
customer's like hey I think there's an
issue with my hot dog and he's like well
what what's the issue with the hot dog
he's like yeah so like my hot dog
doesn't have first of all any mustard on
it or ketchup and also it has a bag of
cocaine in it
inside the hot dog yeah what an instant
wrap so was it next to the hot dog meat
or was it inside of the meat it was
inside of the meat
wow oh do you have a picture
he's like not even playing along anymore
but x-ray of the hot dog
do they say if there was fentanyl in it
so this lady this lady she gets her hot
dog right and she bites into it and she
she discovers she bitten into a plastic
bag oh my God
she could have [__] died her teeth
weren't that sharp she didn't get any
Coke in her mouth so she says yeah cause
what if it was Fenton on that [__] she's
dead she's [__] dead she stays there
for her nose
damn dude what a what a weird mistake to
make who made that mistake is my
question no dude so yeah this uh this
woman or this person
the name Salazar all right this
Christian Jeffrey David Salazar was a
witness on camera with another Sonic
employee a woman right and there
appeared to be like some kind of
hand-to-hand transaction right like
little dab situation like Shredder in
the beginning of Ninja Turtles the movie
they're selling drugs out of a Sonic and
then the next thing that they know like
if you know he um all of a sudden after
he makes the food I'm not kidding it
says
um that he appears to frantically search
the area oh my God as if he lost
something
really do be losing their actual drug
baggie like that do you think those guys
are like pretty on top of where they put
their drugs like you think they would be
right like because cocaine's expensive
it's very expensive you you'd have an
individual pocket where you're like but
if you're high that's true also too if
you're focused like Nikki right if
Nikki's doing something I cannot
interrupt her if I interrupt her even
just quickly like hey babe I need a
quick dab and she's like oh yeah
right then she just lost track yeah and
then all of a sudden she's like
you know what I do though I just Shuffle
it so I'm a one-track person right so
I'm like okay I'm in crypto mode right
now Nikki needs a hug right now Shuffle
I'm in hug mode okay I'm not doing both
yeah I shuffled it I'm in hug bugs but
how do you do you have ADV though before
you started no how do you go back to
where you started I leave my computer
screen up where I was so wait wait when
you look at the screen it looks the same
to you yeah it's exactly where I left it
oh yeah I know exactly why I was there
so it's just like it's just like when
I'm formatting a thought here it's like
oh I don't think yeah so do you think
that's a pretty clear sign of 80d of
like being like hyper focused and then
like you get snapped some way some other
direction you get [__] and then
because for me that's like this like a
train track is going this way right when
something is now implanted in my head it
goes this way and then there's no way to
go back to the track I think I have 80d
then no way Jose it goes like this
hey do you want water yeah and then you
go wait what about can I get ice and
then it's already gone the Train's
[__] gone dude
computer we don't talk about [__] ice
and then when I come back to the time
they made ice was in fuel Japan
and I'm back to the computer and I'm
just like
[__] all right
chapter one
bro I feel like I'm just I think
I have to leave my computer and [__] and
the tabs the same way yeah but then I
have to write what my thoughts and
feelings are at that time when you stop
so when I go back I reread this good or
else I can see the same [__] but I'm not
seeing the same [__] you know as long as
I see it I remember why I was there I do
use memory triggers
um to do it later and in my notes is
that what else do you guys use to like
keep you on track because I feel like I
suffer from this I just go like this
watch talk to me when I'm working hey
[Laughter]
another way to fix it no you know what
also works it works to go like like this
what oh yeah yeah yeah yeah ladies love
it
my relationship is growing great too
do you have it do I no for sure
like Bart Scooby-Doo no how do you how
do you deal with it yeah I know
everything I have I have a whole list of
things I need to do and I have ideas I'm
like writing it down and be like what if
the little Debbies are big daddies
and your wife comes in and she's like oh
no oh it's gone we're too dumb to even
simulate a fake ending win
I have so many notes on my phone right
because of like ideas or whatever I have
to write it down and then I look I look
back I'll try to do like a note clean up
once a month and some of the ideas I
wrote down 17 times
the same [__] thing my notes app is a
[__] mess okay no way I have it like
in different places too yeah because I
have one in a notebook I have one in my
phone one on my desktop one on here yeah
and some of this stuff might be like one
word yeah mine too get a dispenser
dude I think I have 80d and then you I'm
like but it says get us dispenser 17
times
15 different pages
Trails like that because that's like you
know when you're in Forest right and you
[__] have a little [__] Trail to
go back that's what it is
um it's like it's like memory Trails
breadcrumbs it's also hard when like
that reminds me of when when we would
create dance moves which I know you're
gonna love right and then you like you
go okay great that was awesome let's
name it so you name it and then the next
day you look at it you go what the [__]
was even a turtle what was a German
torpedo Del Sol
sounds pretty [__] yeah and then no
one can know it was we're like I don't
know we spent hours now we don't know it
could be you could be interrupted and go
right back
like to what you were thinking about if
that if that thought is like super
prominent what I'm stuck on I'm stuck on
thinking about the whole day if I'm like
okay I need to get this I need to get
this thing done because it leads to this
and if I get back into I'll be I'll be
okay
um
because sometimes I'll get so like like
either my two thoughts got mixed or
whatever and I'm just like trying to
remember something but something came up
there's times when I'm like [__] where
the [__] up in my wallet whatever and
then I go and I look the whole house I
can't find it and I found it in the
trash can because like I'm doing
something else and then the wallet was
something else in that moment the wallet
was in my wallet it was because oh I
needed a throw jury duty away
allegedly allegedly to-do list
in the trash can and the jury duty
envelope in my backpack
if you go to the store you pay with your
jersey yeah
here you are
just like I'm [__] rich
this guy hates wallets
[Laughter]
I'm so rich when I'm developing ideas
brainstorming or when I'm constructing
the question in my mind to come out with
the rest of the things I need to do
that's when I can't be interrupted
because that's where it [__] me up like
when you're developing a concept or like
create like when you're in the
processing
versus like I know what I need to do and
I need to finish that job that's
completely different yeah that's easier
yeah it's like yeah I think that's more
task oriented yeah but when you're doing
something creative then it's like when
you're doing some thinking yeah yeah
I'd end up doing 50 million things at
once you usually are doing a lot of
things at once I think I'm yeah you're
literally doing 20 things right now yeah
I'm killing two birds of One Stop
raising these pups when you're a dad bro
like you just you just don't have time
to do anything else you know I can't
wait man
that looks so easy
dude this is the easiest thing ever
what was this about
it's about that exact thing right there
Sonic hot dogs and cocaine
wow that was a whole journey it was
almost like we did like a little
microcos on what added yeah is that why
this show so were there any charges
filed for any of this uh there isn't
arrest warrant for what and yeah they
knew who the culprit was the guy says
that he purchased the cocaine from
someone in the restaurants parking lot
God damn you ever seen that video Bobby
Brown doing a live concert and cocaine
bag falls out of his pocket and he uses
his dance move to pick it up
it's so smooth
[Music]